à qui va remplacer jean pierre pernaut
les chéris eh bien on a trois candidats
ils sont là ils vont nous faire le jt ce
soir important le premier attention
voilà la première c'est une femme ce
serait bien de voir une femme ou cité 13
heures c'est isabelle morini bosc
regardez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ballet ou toujours dans les régions un
petit tour maintenant dans le puy de
dôme avec un ingrédient qui commence à
ras du succès alors il ay noir rendez
vous avec le programme et c'est cela qui
est remis
[Applaudissements]
girard est devenu presque incontournable
et son meilleur argument c'est de jouer
sur l'effet de surprise en faisant
goûter par petits bouts alors bien
évidemment la montre c'est dingue
bon c'est une cata
on poursuit avec on va mettre non à m
benjamin castaldi
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs bonsoir direction
le nord à la rencontre du chef anthony
marciano qui avait les rendez vous mais
voilà c'est vrai de tromper lui c'est le
vélo vers nos parents nos berne et à
kloten a acquis son corps oui faut lui
donner le texte comme celle de 80 ex
simon sibo sibon ancrée bonsoir à tous
je dédie direction level pour découvrir
un endroit extraordinaire c'est près de
la ville d'ambert connu pour son fromage
plus qui cache le plus vieux bourg à
papier encore en activité c'est ce que
nous raconte loïc flandre à et alex
israël et franck appietto au xviie
siècle au coeur de l'auvergne
on comptait pas moins de 300 moulin à
papier et bien belles traditions ses
pairs c'est pas possible d'être aussi
nul
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il ay la sentant d'animation là haut que
j'ai vu en linge il s'est entraîné un
très net
mes frères c'est comme ça mais c'est kg
c'est une catastrophe comme mes frères
allée jean michel maire
[Musique]
il a donné rendez vous mardi dans son
village pour nous faire découvrir sa
recette d'agneau revisitée qui ne laisse
pas indifférent les petits comme les
qualités d'un grand reportage et je
pense que compass c'est dans une ferme
des flandres cantona vient chercher ses
fruits et légumes et son choix se porte
aujourd'hui sur des asperges qu'il va
marier avec l'incontournable de pâques
chocolat
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
ce match parce que les trois avaient
peur de peinture est vrai quand à la
bataille mais fait il a toujours le cas
mais j'ai vu jean michel maire armand et
enlever ses lunettes il s'est dit la
barbie